und plötzlich klopft es an der tür
klopft klopf klopf klopf oder so weiß
nicht leute ich bin jetzt eure ninja
ball nicht mehr alex ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich das um habt also okay wir
fangen erst mal alle leute was klappt
herzlich willkommen beim neuen video
endlich wieder aus ganz natürlicher wie
es gewohnt seid perspektive jetzt gibt
es wieder videos jeden tag habe ja schon
gesagt also diese woche wäre echt heftig
morgen kommt ein video donnerstag kommt
ein video freizeitkomplex trieb auf
jeden fall kommen jetzt wieder richtig
viele videos auf die ihr euch wirklich
richtig freuen können
da wird viel cooles zeug dabei sein und
ich habe wieder richtig lust deswegen
jetzt jeden tag ich würde mal sagen 18
uhr manchmal schaue ich vielleicht nicht
ganz aber freut euch jeden tag so da
kopf dass irgendwas kommt immer hoffe
ich manchmal vielleicht nicht ich will
jetzt auch gar nicht lange lagern ihr
denkt euch wahrscheinlich warum hat ja
so ein hässliches ding und im kopf das
steht ihm überhaupt nicht genau das
denkt euch wahrscheinlich oder
vielleicht ja auch nicht ja keine ahnung
ich war letztens shoppen und darf ich
einfach mal zwei von diesen teil
mitgenommen und hab mir jetzt einfach
mal umgebunden ihr könnt ihr meine
kommentare schreiben findet ihr das geht
also ich finde so es sieht gar nicht so
schlimm aus ich hätt's gedacht ist sieht
schlimmer aus also ich finde das ist
okay schreibt mir die kommentare oder
wenn ihr sagt bohr das sieht richtig gut
aus
dann könnt ihr immer gerne nach oben da
lassen wir fangen jetzt an mit dem thema
jetzt wahrscheinlich am titel auch schon
gesehen
es geht heute um eine story die ich euch
ja gestern versprochen hatte dass ihr
euch die erzähle weil die war wirklich
so da dachte ich so jungs mädels mädels
fans auf jeden fall bin ich heute erst
aus dem krankenhaus wieder gekommen also
ich musste noch mal rein
als ich wieder zu hause war das war das
bisschen umständlich ist auch egal
deswegen gab es dieses video nicht schon
eher aber jetzt ist es wirklich an der
zeit ich muss heute zählt weil es
wirklich ok ich muss euch nicht erzählen
dabei ist es unterhaltsam und ich dann
ja auch keine namen also wenn ihr das
seht ich habe mich ich finde es super
dass ihr mich so sehr unterstützt oder
als waren eigentlich mehr als zwei ich
hätte auf der einen seite mit sowas nie
gerechnet weil natürlich auf der einen
seite kann man sagen so was gehört sich
überhaupt nicht das greift in die
privatsphäre ein
auf der anderen seite fand ich es auch
witzig dass das passiert ist okay dann
kommen wir sofort auf den punkt ich weiß
sofort es bisschen komisch ich hab dann
zum
viel müll erzählt auf jeden fall ich war
nicht bei mir zu hause ich habe meiner
freundin und dort reich im krankenhaus
weil das halt da passiert und was willst
du dann machen dann bin ich halt da ist
krankenhaus gegangen und ja sie wird
halt ein bisschen weiter weg von mir
also das war nicht hier wo mich
wahrscheinlich also das ist ja normal
dass wenn youtuber in der und der stadt
wohnen dass da viele oder mehr leute
wissen dass der youtube und in dem
krankenhaus war ich vier tage also von
sonntag bis mittwoch
und ich hab' montag glaube ich oder
sonntagabend schon sonst neff gepostet
bei snap ich mir nichts dabei gedacht so
bei mir war langweilig mein zimmer da
war keiner habe ich bisher das zimmer
gefilmt bisschen nach draußen gefilmter
was anteilig einfach sonntag ein ganz
normaler teil der war nicht schön der
ware nicht hübsch aber auch nicht
hässlich nur ein teil mehr dich und
braune bände drumherum
ok also ich habe diesen snap gemacht und
einfach später habe ich meine freundin
besucht und wir sind zusammen in diesem
part gegangen von dem krankenhaus nichts
böses haben wir uns bei gedacht und dann
sind wir das paar runden gelaufen
wollten wieder reingehen und dann kam
schon so mädchen uns entgegen und
mittlerweile ich weiß einfach so wenn
mich jemand erkennt und wenn mich jemand
nicht kennt das merkt man einfach selbst
wenn jemand noch so leise spricht man
merkt es an hat des blickes anhand des
verhaltens und so weiter und da kann man
halt mädchen und da hat meine freundin
auch sofort schon gesagt die kannten
dich und ich habe mir gedacht ja kann ja
passieren ich meinen jeder darf in den
park rhein kann ja sein dass sie gegen
wien besuchen und dann sind wir heute
hoch auf mein zimmer gegangen
und ja es steht ja nicht irgendwo alex
wie liegt auf zimmer so und so ok und
jetzt kommt wirklich der wirkung das
lustige war nämlich oder was heißt es
lustige arbeit war schon lustig weil
genau an dem oder hellwach auf jeden
fall kamen genau an dem tag noch zwei
weitere patienten auf mein zimmer die
waren beide so um die 60 würde ich sagen
sie kamen frisch aus der narkose hatten
grasen op und würden wieder in mein
zimmer reingeschoben und ich war da halt
auch und wollte möglichst leise sein
damit die da ordentlich also die waren
wirklich richtig für klatsch und lagen
da einfach so
und ich saß da wirklich soweit ich
kennen so eine situation nicht bloß
leise nichts sagen ich habe in meiner
freundin ganz leise karten gespielt
warum auch immer ich kann die spieler
aber ich hab's gemacht so
krankenschwestern kamen eigentlich auch
gar nicht rein weil die werden dann
einfach in ruhe gelassen die dürfen dann
schlafen ihre ruhe haben und wir sollen
halt auch möglichst leise sein und
plötzlich klopft es an der tür klopft
klopf klopf klopf oder so weiß nicht die
tür ging auf und es kamen zwei mädchen
rhein wo ich erst dachte sie gehören
vielleicht zudem oder dem herrn weil das
waren die mädchen die uns im park auch
schon so komisch geguckt haben und diese
mädchen guckt mich an und gucken so
einfach so fünf sekunden oder keine
ahnung die guckt mich einfach an und ich
dachte so und danken dir einfach so
durch letzten mal durch verweigert
diesen beiden schlafenden narkose
patienten zu mir und wollen dass ich mit
rauskommt fotos mache und ich weiß bis
heute nicht wie sie mich gefunden haben
ich meine wie soll das gehen die einzige
wirklich ein leuchtendes story oder
geschichte dahinter könnte für mich sein
dass die wirklichen snap analysiert
haben aus welcher perspektive der
gemacht wurde welches stockwerk das war
aber ich bin mir auch sicher die sind
die zimmer abgeklappert und haben
gekriegt hab ich irgendwo liege oder so
ja und das hat sich dann irgendwie so
ein bisschen rum gesprochen womit ich
auch überhaupt nicht gerechnet habe weil
ich meine ich habe jetzt auch nicht 5
millionen abonnenten oder so und dann
saßen da wirklich noch ein paar andere
mädchen auf dem flur die dann auch noch
kam zu meiner tür
das war auf jeden fall erlebnis für sich
also wenn ich nach meinem krankenhaus
liege wäre es nett wenn ihr am besten
nicht kommt jetzt nicht weil ihr
natürlich auch ein bisschen meine
privatsphäre stellt aber natürlich gibt
es auch andere passieren die sich auch
gestört fühlen aber ich mache euch kein
vorwurf alles gut fand ich wirklich
lustig und ist ja auch eine witzige
story
ihr könnt ja meine kommentare schreiben
was er dass man halt also ich bin
einfach rausgegangen
die meinten dann so ja hallo liebe haben
uns so was wie gesagt keine ahnung wir
haben irgendwie gesagt wir sagen es auch
keinen keine angst blabla und dann sind
ja auch schon wieder ganz gut gegangen
was ja auch ganz lieb fanden dann kann
man sie gesagt nur zwei andere schreibt
eure meinung dazu meine kommentare kann
man so was machen oder sollte man dass
er nicht machen also wie gesagt schreibt
und ihre kommentare ich lese mir die
fleißig durch werte mal ein bisschen mit
euch diskutieren meine meinung
vielleicht ja schon das sollte man
erlassen ist natürlich klar wenn jetzt
auch so sieht oder wenn euch das video
gefallen hat was wir gern noch um da
würde mich sehr freuen
sap zudem könnt ihr mir gerne folgen wir
sind es dann morgen wieder
morgen kommt hoffentlich ein video ich
weiß noch nicht was aber es kommt ein
geiles video wohl warten
wir können versuchen nicht zu lachen
machen bis märz ausmachen ich gucke auf
jeden fall mal war ich weiß ja auch
lange im krankenhaus da kamen nicht ich
habe nicht viel geplant deswegen kann es
sein dass morgen meine freunde noch
einmal dabei ist ich hab ja gesagt ich
will das nicht so gerne ist jetzt
irgendwie auch schon untergegangen
er hat drei leute aber nicht vergessen
nächstes überlassen ist